(laughing)
- I am not popular on Instagram, at all.
Today, I'm asking a bunch
of people that I work with,
a bunch of people I don't work
with, anyone I can think of,
I'm asking them to flood my
Instagram with notifications.
(electronic music)
So have you ever turned
on your notifications?
- Like on to my phone?
- Yeah.
Like push notifications.
So that's what I had at the beginning
of when I started BuzzFeed
and then I was in a video
that like popped off, and then
I turned those things off.
(suspenseful music)
- It's still not giving
me push notifications.
(suspenseful music)
So, Spenser gets push
notifications on Instagram,
which means it's possible.
I'm gonna add my account
to Spenser's phone.
My concern is why does
yours work and none of,
literally no one else's does.
(suspenseful music)
Two minutes till fresh
content, let's do this.
- What's happening?
- Oh, you need to follow
Spenser right now.
- This is really making
me rethink the content
I have on my Instagram.
- Jessica, spread the word.
- Jessica, you spread the word
- Bye!
- Flood Spenser!
- [Woman] Terrifying!
(screaming)
- I've never clicked
"like" so much in my life.
- It looks pretty cool.
It looks like a waterfall, and it's funny,
because we called it a flood.
Spenser got a lot of
attention today, which,
she probably loved, right?
Woo hoo!
Thank you everybody!
Yay!
- [Woman] Yeah, you did it.
(upbeat music)